brace yourself believers because it
Justin Bieber has deleted is Instagram
yes it is Justin because this means all
your beautiful and sometimes
inappropriate pics are Donna forever
I don't want to read negative stuff and
then people upset you know of course
this all comes after the Biebs and
excellent ago mez seemingly got in a
little war of words in the comments
section of one of Bieber's of final
posts he was sharing snaps with Sophia
Ricci who might be his new girlfriend
and fans were attacking the pair just in
it threatened to go private if the hate
and it stopped and Selena appeared to
write quote if you can't handle the hate
then stop posting pictures of your
girlfriend lol it should be special
between you two only and the whole thing
seemed to spiral into a back-and-forth
over alleged infidelity
so far Sofia has kept her page alive but
comment free continuing to share new
pics as the drama unfolds while Selena
might regret getting involved in all of
it
she snapchatted this cryptic message
late Monday what I said it was selfish
and pointless